welcome to physics 801 mi t--'s
introductory course in classical
mechanics for first-year undergraduates
I'm deep toe Chakrabarti and I'm Peter
dorm Ashkan we're the faculty members in
charge of this course the science of
classical mechanics establishes an
important principle of cause and effect
wherein the changes in a body's motion
arise from the application of physical
forces Newton's laws of motion
established a scientific principle of
analyzing observed phenomenon through
the use of clearly articulated
mathematical models rather than through
intuition these concepts are so
important to the modern branches of
science and engineering that we require
all of our undergraduates at MIT to take
classical mechanics regardless of
whatever course they intend to
specialize it in many high school level
physics courses mechanics is taught as a
set of formulas to memorize for a series
of standard situations our course is
different here you will learn a set of
fundamental principles that you can use
to apply to unfamiliar situations and
analyze them rather than just situations
that you studied previously 801 assumes
a strong background in high school level
physics and mathematics we introduce and
make extensive use of calculus as needed
so a previous course in calculus is not
a prerequisite however it is a rigorous
and technically challenging course aimed
at MIT undergraduates ADA ones
OpenCourseWare site contains a coherent
set of lessons that will take you
through all the basic concepts of
classical mechanics as well as a set of
advanced topics including mass flow
simple harmonic motion and processional
motion in each of these lessons you will
find a series of short lightboard videos
that will help you understand concepts
mathematical derivations and
problem-solving techniques in addition
you will find many other useful
resources including an online textbook
many worked example problems and MIT
level problem sets developing a command
of mechanics is a powerful tool for
understanding the world around us
welcome data one
you